after brexit Parliament's is set to  downsize the number of seats from 751 to  705 with 27 seats redistributed to  underrepresented countries the 46  remaining seats will be kept for  countries that may join in the future as  the ship aquarius carrying 629 migrants  was finally welcomed by spain members  urged leaders to end the migration  crisis in a debate while setting their  priorities for the next EU summit Prime  Minister Mark Rutte / of the Netherlands  was the seventh EU leader to debate the  future of Europe with parliament members  cyber attacks have no borders amid these  new threats mep xored european armed  forces to work together including closer  cooperation with NATO with the number of  drones set to skyrocket members have  updated aviation security rules for an  industry that's expected to create a  hundred and fifty thousand jobs by 2050